i know you're super humble
uh saying it's better to be lucky than
good but
your story is inspiring that
the entire trajectory of having a dream
of accomplishing that dream
of having one hell of a career what
advice
would you give to a young person to a
young version of yourself
today that listens to this and is
inspired that wants to fly
or wants to go to space who wants to
build the rocket is there advice
you could give them about life about
career
about anything yeah yeah um
first let me start with uh and you had a
question on
inspirational people so my grandfather i
had mentioned him earlier
huge funeral beer delivery guy
was delivering beer and the 60s riots
were the the
guys the black in the black
neighborhoods where you know white
people didn't go
and my grandfather's sicilian he was one
of the first ones in his family born in
the united states so
my great-grandmother and i had aunts and
uncles that i knew growing up that
actually came over on the boat
um huge huge guy and just the nicest
friendliest would give you the shirt off
his back obviously proven by his funeral
and i'm talking at his funeral
the head of the black panthers was at
his funeral in in toledo ohio the mafia
guys were at his funeral in toledo ohio
uh i mean it was literally a mix of of
of who's who
and uh he had told me once you know
because when you're little you start
looking and i grew up basically
i was probably middle class lower middle
class my dad was a fireman you're not
rich he's working for the city it was a
paycheck to paycheck living is how i
grew up
and i was talking to my grandfather one
day and he said something to me and this
is this is literally how i run my life
he said
it was about money because you'd see you
know back in the day if you saw someone
in a mercedes that was rare
you know they weren't everywhere you
know people did you couldn't lease the
car he actually bought a car and usually
bought a car with cash
um so it's a totally different than we
are now and he said
he goes you know david he goes they're
no better than you and you're no better
than anyone else
he goes you got to remember that he goes
everyone's different he goes treat
everyone with the respect and dignity
that they deserve
he goes and if they're poor if they're
homeless he goes it doesn't make him a
bad person
it just that's that's who they chose to
be and you make
choices in your life but never ever look
down on someone because
you know there will always be someone
that will look down on you and you
should never ever do that
and i kept that close to me he was a
huge influence as my mom's dad
um just a big big influence in my life
and the way i carried myself um and he
was one that would say
you know you can be anything you want to
be you know he grew up dirt poor
you know and the fact that he had bought
a house and took good care of my
grandmother and did stuff like that
you know to him that was a success and
to me it was always you know trying to
better and move on
and he was the one you know my parents
were a big part of this too
was instilling that anything is possible
so when i'm four years and 11 months old
in 1969 you know and i'm watching neil
armstrong walk on the moon and i'm
asking my mom and she says well they
were all military pilots and you know we
had an international guard that at the
time was flying f-100 so i'm dating
myself
um i i was just fascinated with flight
and i just looked at that going that's
really what i want to do and i never
lost sight of that there was always i
could do this or do that and
when i was going to go to college before
i enlisted in the marine corps i was
accepted into natural resources at ohio
state and i'm like ah
if i can't fly i'll go be a forest
ranger because i wanted to hang out in
one of those towers in colorado and look
for fires because that's just i like
that stuff
you know it was that or be an
oceanographer because i was fascinated
with jacques cousteau and i actually
that's my degree
my undergrad degree is jacques cousteau
so influences are neil armstrong
and john cousteau i have an oceanography
degree i got an mba from university of
houston goku's got to mention them and
then
uh and so you're looking people go what
are you going to do with that and i said
you know i got an oceanography degree
because i go well i'm going to sail on
the ocean so at least
if the ship sinks i'll know where i'm at
and that was a kind of a running joke
and then
and then there's so these passions and
underneath it is the
is the belief that you can be anything
you want to be you can
you know i told my kids this you know
when they were young
you know it was tough especially for my
son so when nate was about five six
years we knew nate was colorblind
you know my my wife's brothers are both
colorblind it's really color deprived
clarity blind you see black and white
he can't tell he has issues with greens
reds browns it's funny if you're ever
around someone like that
because he'll go i'll go what are you
looking at he goes right over there by
the red thing i'm like what are you
looking at
i go this like he had a hat on one
dagger which one are you gonna he had a
hat in his hand it was green he goes i'm
gonna get the green one i go oh this one
right here he goes no the one on my head
i go nate that one's
brown he's like leave me alone dad he
got the brown hat because to him it
looked great
yeah so he couldn't fly he came he said
i go what do you want to do nate you
know you're talking to your kids and
what do you want to use i want to be a
pilot no now i got to tell him because
he's looking at me because i'm a pilot
do you can't be a pilot he's like why
can't i be a pilot i said because
you you got eye issues you know so you
got to redirect
and the other one was because i had i
stopped flying i was 42 years old
and i was like and it was my childhood
dream so it's like a pro athlete i know
exactly what it feels like
when you know brett favre has to walk
away from the nfl when you still can do
it
good choice of quarterback by the way
the greatest of all time but whatever
so you you do when you look at it and
you go
i understand what those guys feel like
when you have to walk away from
something that you love and you think
you can still do it
um so i told them i said look
i was talking to both my kids and i said
you know find something that you
want to do that you love to do and that
you can do your whole life
and you should be able to do good things
for other people
you want to be able to help other people
that's what i said
so both of my kids and there is no one
in my family both of my children one of
them is
my daughter is a doctor uh doing
residency in internal medicine right now
and my son is in his third year and
they're both gonna be doctors
and so i look at it is you know people
go oh you got two doctors i don't care i
told my kids if you want to be a garbage
man
or you want to dig ditches i don't care
just be be the best ditch digger that
you can be
i said and be happy doing it because
what you also find is that
we are in this big pursuit of money
money money money might be that's what
makes the world go round but
what you realize and i'll go back to my
grandfather who didn't have a lot of
money
and he was probably one of the most
happy people on life and unfortunately
he died
he died at 65. he had a massive heart
attack because he didn't
tell that he he kind of knew it was
happening and he just made the choice to
to do and it was devastating to the
entire family
but he didn't he didn't have a lot of
money but i'll tell you what i know a
lot of rich people who have funerals and
there's nobody adam
yeah and my grandfather who's a beer
delivery guy had i i it literally it was
like three miles long the pope
it was crazy yeah who died the po that
was because it was like he's a catholic
he's just you know italian he goes
you know who died the pope and i go now
that's my grandfather and then the next
funeral i went to was my aunt his sister
and there was like you know 30 people
and i looked at my mother and i said
where's everybody at
she goes oh no this is normal
this is what a normal funeral looks like
so it's
you know for young kids bottom line one
be nice kindness will get you i'm a big
believer in karma
kindness will get you a long way in the
world you know it's easy
it's it it's easy to be nice it doesn't
cost you anything
i said you know and get rid of the hate
and number two is
follow your dreams because everyone is
capable of everything and there's a
there's a self realism like
you know if you really have trouble with
math getting a phd in applied math is
probably not something you're going to
be able to do
but understand yourself what your own
capabilities are and you know inside
your heart don't let anyone ever tell
you what you can and can't do you have
to determine that yourself
and go for it and and and you can do
anything
it's just it's it's a great the world's
incredible
it really is
you